ANOTHER.
FINALLY, CLEANED
ARE READY.
>> Dell: ANOTHER TOUGH REBOUND.
>> CAPITAL OF
THE WORLD GOT ROCKED TO THE
CORE.
>> GOT 15.
>> Ryan: CALLED.
AND THE ROCKETS CANNOT BEBE
HIS HEAD DOWN.
>> I THOUGHT HEY THE WAY.
JAKOB GOT THAT BALL.
LONNIE WAS WIDE OPEN,PLAYER OF
POINTERS, THAT I HAVE SEE
COMING.
>> Doris: NO, AND THE
TRADE BUCKETS.
YOU WANT TO GET STOPS AND YO
HERRO, LOB, THEY'RE GOING TO
GET IT HELP
WITH F FOROR J JEFEFF F GRGRE.
S S FAFABUBULOLOUSUS I INN EN
THE HIGHLIGHTS WILL COME.
BUT, YOU KN- OH!
JACK FOUR
MONK SMILES AT PORTER AS THEY  A
TEAM.
WADEDE
HAS ULD TURN OUT TO BE. TO GET
HIM SWITCHED ONTO RUSSELL
WESTBROOK.
>> Mikik TEMPO
DIFFERENCE WHEN DEMAR IS OFF
DERRICK JONES JR. MAKING SURE
TH THUMPER.
>> Greg: HEY, I SAW IT STOP THAN
>> Stan: WOW.
I TECHNICAL FOULS
ALREADY.
>> Ian: DINWIDDIE THAT DUNK, L